in the last video we talked about
g-protein coupled receptors in their
general scheme but we mentioned two
different second messengers cyclic AMP
II and then we also talked about I P 3
and D AG in this video I want to talk
specifically about cyclic AMP II because
it's particularly important I think so
what happens with cyclic AMP e we have a
hormone come on over and bind just like
it we did talked about in the other
video triggers a conformational change
in the g-protein coupled receptor
triggering a change in the G protein
causing the G alpha subunit to leave
with its attached G TP over to the
effector enzyme so the G alpha subunit
one with its GTP attached and it's act
now that it's active it'll head over to
its effector enzyme in the case of
cyclic a and P this effector enzyme
specifically is called Edina light
cyclase or sick lace I'm not exactly
sure whatever the point is this is how
it's spelled what does this enzyme do
basically what it does is it takes ATP's
and turns them into cyclic a.m. PS and
of course a pyrophosphate so these two
clicking B's are the second messengers
now this adenylate cyclase as long as
it's active meaning as long as it's just
this g protein this g alpha subunit with
his GTP is here it's going to keep
making a bunch of cyclic AMP YZ now what
are these cyclic a and PS do in the
previous video we talked about how they
trigger a particular cell response well
specifically how do they do that
what they do is they activate these
things called cyclic AMP II dependent
protein kinase a--'s so what is a cyclic
AMP e dependent protein kinase well
first of all they're taking protease
protein kinases and taking them from a
less active stay
to a more active state so basically what
we're doing is we're activating these
protein kinases so what is the protein
kinase well what what do they do if you
recall when we talked about kinase is we
said that kinase is add a phosphate
group right from ATP to something they
add phosphate groups from ATP in this
specific case what is this kinase adding
a phosphate to it's adding it to a
protein in this specific case that
something is a target protein so what's
going on there so one cyclic GMP has
activated these protein kinases that are
dependent on cyclic AMP es availability
once we have them active what they're
going to do is they're going to add
phosphates to target proteins so they're
our target proteins that initially have
no phosphates on them these protein
kinases will catalyze the reaction in
which these target proteins are have a
phosphate group but attached to them or
they'll catalyze the reaction that adds
the phosphate group to the target
protein now what are these target
proteins typically well what they really
what they are is typically their
cellular enzymes and we'll talk about
specific examples later so adding that
phosphate to this target protein - this
is an enzyme right if this enzyme has a
phosphate on it what does the addition
of that phosphate activate or inhibit
that enzyme again it depends right we
don't really know all we know is that
adding a phosphate group changes the
structure of a protein does that change
in structure activate it or inhibit it
make it better at doing its job or worse
at doing this job I don't know it
depends it depends on the particular
case but regardless that's going to
change the activity of this target
protein so that change in activity is is
sort of the cell response okay so that's
what's going on with the second
messenger being sick okay MP there are
these cyclic GMP dependent protein
kinases that activate or inactivate
certain target proteins and the changes
in the activity of those target proteins
is basically what determines the cell
response I hope that video is helpful
one last thing i'm atutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email at Luffy University at
gmail.com thank you for watching